North Korea claims to have tested a new
high-tech weapon and says the missile
launch was meant as a warning to us
allies South Korea North Korea released
these pictures of leader Kim jong-un
overseeing yesterday's launch of two
short-range ballistic missiles into the
sea
now South Korea says the weapons were
similar to this russian-made missile
that flies lower and can make in-flight
adjustments think of that the launches
were the first since President Trump
briefly entered North Korea last month
during his latest meeting with Kim CBS
News senior foreign affairs
correspondent and Face the Nation
moderator Margaret Brennan is in
Washington and she joins us now Margaret
good morning we should remind people
that this region of the world is vitally
important to the global economy and
global security five nuclear declared
nations already the u.s. is hoping North
Korea will not become number six does
this test setback those negotiations
well president Trump is basically saying
he's gonna overlook these two missile
tests they were fired into the Sea of
Japan his national security adviser was
in the region but the president is
giving Kim jong-un a pass because he
wants to get that stalled diplomacy
going both he and secretary Pompeo
publicly dismissed the test last night
saying they're only short-range which
that does pose a threat to America's
allies but not here on the US mainland
so it is still worth pointing out though
as our David Martin has reported that
the Pentagon notes the u.s. had no
warning these tests were about to happen
which suggests North Korea's ability to
covertly develop weapons is getting
better hmm Margaret I remember you were
at that failed summit in Vietnam back in
the day do you think now that the talks
have stalled between the two countries
they have stalled and that's why
President Trump took that extraordinary
trip to the DMZ and stepped into North
Korea last month this was a play to try
to get the talks going again but no
meetings have taken place since that why
do you think they've stolen well North
Korea so far doesn't want to give up any
part of their program they continue to
develop their their weapons they want
the u.s. to pull back sanctions so far
they have
gotten what they wanted in the US hasn't
gotten what it wants but at those those
presidential levels they come out all
smiles with the hope of negotiations is
the working-level that just is stalled
secretary Pompeo said last night in a
handful of weeks he thinks there may be
another meeting scheduled but that would
be with someone called the US envoy
Steve bacon so Margaret while we're
trying to negotiate with North Korea the
United States is also participating in a
joint military operation military drills
with South Korea so what's the
geopolitical strategy of the u.s. in the
region well you know this fight in the
region there about 30,000 US troops
stationed on the peninsula they practice
these drills every year with our ally in
order to show readiness but North Korea
continues to think that this is
preparation for an invasion the u.s.
presence on the peninsula has been there
to offset the threat from North Korea
but as you know in Asia the big concern
is the growing threat from China and so
there is little appetite for pulling out
entirely all right Margaret the tensions
continue there in the region thank you
very much Sunday on Face the Nation
Margaret speaks with acting White House
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney she'll also
talk to the vice chairman of the Senate
Intelligence Committee that's Democratic
Senator Mark Warner and Democratic
presidential candidate Marianne
Williamson that is Sunday here on CBS